[Music]
well welcome to Sophie and calm Sophie
Sharon not said in our last program we
talked about israeli-palestinian
tensions hearing the Palestinian
perspective so are the prospects of
lasting peace fading today I asked
Admiral ami Ayalon the former head of
Shin Bet Israel's domestic security
service and commander-in-chief of
Israeli Navy the unresolved conflict
over Palestine is hurting Israel's
position on the international stage and
sparking a rise in anti-semitism
threatening Jewish communities all over
the world but with Palestinians divided
and Israeli voters leaning towards
hardline action can there be any real
progress towards peace will any Israeli
politician be bold enough to start
untangling decades of hatred and how
long contention simmer before they blow
up once again
Admiral ami Ayalon former head of Israel
Shin Bet Security Service and
commander-in-chief of Israeli Navy
welcome to the show it is great to have
you with us Admiral so the
israeli-palestinian tensions are rising
and people are killed during Gaza
protests Olmos on a weekly basis and the
UN middle-east and we weren't just
recently that the risk of war continues
to loom large is a new Gaza war looming
if you ask me we are heading violence
and we are heading a war future the
level of violence is very difficult to
predict because finally as I understand
the Palestinian side they are not united
there is a lot of energy among the
Palestinians but until now it was not
directed only against Israel
it is a combination of humiliation
feeling of humiliation
and in despair so in the immediate
future I'm not sure that we shall see
violence but for the long run yes for
sure so whether it will be on the yes so
at this point the Palestinian leadership
seems to have lost trust in Americans as
mediators and it stands against Trump's
upcoming service a deal of the century
as he puts it even before it's unveiled
will the deal be dead on delivery the
support to Abu Mazen among Palestinians
is is less than 30 or 25 percent in
addition of course the gap between the
American administration and the
Palestinian Authority is huge as they do
not speak to each other so on top of the
of the lack of confidence of the
Palestinians in their leadership they do
not have any confidence in the
international community so they are
heading to a state of despair which is
becoming very very dangerous by the way
both in Gaza and and in the West Bank in
addition of course the Israeli
government Israeli administration does
not help not to Abu Mazen in order to
get his power again because it seems
that my government are the Israeli
administration do not have any interest
in creating any kind of peace process or
any kind of negotiations that will lead
to a better future for the Israelis and
for the Palestinians so when when we
shall face violence what kind of
violence whether it will it will it will
be led by Hamas or or by the Palestinian
Authority or whether it will be a kind
of a popular
uprising that we here call Intifada no
one can predict okay I don't ask you a
few more questions about this deal
former US ambassador to United Nations
nikki Haley actually lifted the veil a
little bit and said that Palestinians
are set to benefit more from this deal
and the Israelis would risk more what do
you read in this does this mean that the
Israeli won't love Trump's ideas as well
when I listen especially to American
voices during the last 20 years they do
not understand the Middle East they do
not understand Palestinians and if you
ask me they do not understand Israel the
way I believe Israel should be so if you
ask me about the future deal
my assumption my assumption is that
Israeli administration will not be too
happy Palestinians will not be able to
accept it because if again if I
understand it is not based on on the
usual assumptions you have to understand
that during the last 25 30 years the
international community accepted the
assumptions of future agreement between
Palestinians and Israelis will be based
on international resolutions Security
Council resolutions 242 3 3 8 and since
2002 the Arab League peace plan was
added but if I understand Trump he
cannot promise this kind of promise not
because he does not believe that it is a
rational promise or a rational process
mainly because he is trapped by his base
in order to be elected again
in less than two years so he cannot
deliver any plan which is based on these
assumptions this is my prediction
so after recognizing Jerusalem as
Israel's capital Donald Trump said that
Israelis won a very big thing now
Palestinians will get something good
because it's their turn as he puts it if
United States now recognizes is
Jerusalem as Palestine's capital what
will they Israeli reaction be if the
Arab neighborhoods of Jerusalem will be
or will will become in the future the
capital of future Palestine but it will
be one issue in a package in order to
create a future of two states along the
lines of 67 with exchange of territory
swap and in addition that will ensure
the Israeli security I believe that it
will be acceptable and of course it will
be accepted by the international
community I believe that it will be
accepted by many Israelis if you ask me
whether it will be accepted by our
political community I am Not sure we
shall have to see you know I spoke
recently to President Mahmoud Abbas his
advisor and he told me that israel needs
to accept two-state solution or it risks
slipping into a one-state reality and
de-facto
a Perseids state is this where Israel is
heading right now look again if you ask
me what he told you is exactly what I
see around me
we Wiesel is we have to choose whether
to whether we want to see Israel as a
Jewish Democratic state based based on
the ideas of our Declaration of
Independence
we can achieve this kind of future only
within the context of two states because
the precondition in order to see Israel
as a Jewish Democratic state is us Jews
being majority in our state if we are
not majority in our state we do not have
the power and we do not have the right
to dictate the public space to dictate
the language the calendar or the stories
and narratives that we tell our story
our children at schools so our only
choice is to state agreement or solution
but can I ask you something Admiral the
test can ask you some of the two-state
solution though has been more or less
accepted scenario for a long time now
but the Israeli settlements in the West
Bank continued to grow in number and
criss-crossing the Palestinian territory
how can Palestine have a separate state
when it has all the settlement starting
its map because if we shall achieve this
agreement settlers most of them will
have to come back to Israel and I
believe that when we shall negotiate
with the Palestinians we shall have to
negotiate on the future of those Jews
Israeli settlers who prefer to stay in
Palestine we shall have to negotiate
whether they will will have to accept
Palestinian citizenship or any kind of
solution or unfortunately they will have
to come back it will be very painful it
will be very painful
so the Palestinian problem with
settlements is an important block to
peace but it's obvious that no
politician in Israel has the power to
uproot them
like it happen in Gaza even if someone
wanted to what is the way out of the
situation in the past we we brought back
settlers from Egypt and
and we brought back settlers from Gaza
in different circumstances so in order
to create this new reality which does
not exist today we have to we have to
convince Israelis is that when we bring
back our people when we bring back
settlers we shall not get violence and
terror but we shall get peace because
you have to understand the Israeli
narrative is every time when we brought
back when we approved settlements the
Palestinian response was more violence
and more thorough more than everything
the Israelis want to feel secure and as
long as we shall feel that when we bring
back our people we shall get more terror
the chances are to see this kind of move
decreasing every day Admiral we're going
to take a short break right now when
we're back we'll continue our discussion
of the palestinian-israeli tensions with
Admiral ami Ayalon former head of
Israel's Sheen that Security Service and
commander-in-chief of the Israeli Navy
stay with us
[Music]
and we're back with Admiral ami Ayalon
former head of Israel's Shin Bet
Security Service and commander-in-chief
of the Israeli Navy discussing the
Middle Eastern peace process so Admiral
President Abbas's advisor also told me
that the Netanyahu government was pretty
much unwilling to make any progress on
israeli-palestinian peace now the
Israeli public figures generals advisers
all of them tell me that it's the
Palestinians who don't want to make
progress does neither party really want
to move forward look I believe that the
tragedy of this region is that the gap
between the two narratives if you will
ask the average Israeli he will tell you
all what we wanted is security and we
gave them everything and we gave them
territory and and what we got back was
more terror more violence and Intifada
and we are right this is exactly what
happened on the other hand there is a
contradicting Palestinian narrative that
tells you look all what we wanted is to
see the end of occupation and to get our
freedom and our state and all what we
sow is more settlements more roadblocks
more military units and everything was a
conspiracy American Israeli conspiracy
in order to build more settlements to
gain more time and to come to us and to
tell us listen it's too bloody late you
know it's a we we we cannot bring
hundreds of thousands of settlers back
to Israel we do not see their narrative
they do not see our narrative and what
we really need is someone from outside
in the past we had the Americans we lost
them
because they they lost the Palestinians
so they they cannot intermediate between
us and the Palestinians
so somebody for
outside should come and telling us look
from outside this is exactly what I see
and the international community could
care less so I'm afraid I'm afraid that
we are heading to I don't know a very
good feature whether it will be a kind
of Intifada or whether it will be a kind
of sanctions I don't know what will
happen on the day after Abu Mazen
whoever wins April's elections in Israel
will the elected leader be in the
position to make any concessions to the
Palestinians without a broad public
outcry look it's it's very difficult to
predict because if if you really listen
to the voices today of our political
leaders it is not very promising if we
if we really listen to yella peat or to
Bennigan's who probably prefer to create
coalition weaselly could even without
Netanyahu so I can tell you that
probably we shall have the same the same
policy but without corruption so it will
not it will not save us from ourselves
and we shall not change the political
direction so I'm not very optimistic
when I really hear the voices among
Israeli politics today there is a
tension between Hamas and Fatah and
there is no United Palestinian front for
Israel to talk to but do you even need
one I mean why not reach a deal with for
example the West Bank right now and deal
with Gaza later look I believe that by
the way most Israelis would accept your
offer I
I think that it will not work it will
not work because finally you know in
Gaza about 2 million people are living
and and we tend to forget that they are
human being
many of them are starving but in
addition to starvation they say they
feel that they are living in a prison so
even if we prefer to deal with with the
Palestinians on the West Bank and to
delay any solution on Gaza on on the
side of Gaza reality will not let us
this luxury second whether we like it or
not and and I'm not sure that all the
Palestinians like it but but the
Palestinians sees themselves as one
people with all the gap with all the
differences between the people who are
living in Gaza and the people who are
living in the West Bank after so many
years of separation they says there are
many many differences cultural
ideological political between them but
we they see themselves as one people no
matter what you or or anybody else
really sink or want I want to talk to
you a little bit about America's
withdrawal from Syria which as far as I
understand for now will see only 200
peacekeepers stay in the country now the
mood in America is to disengage from the
region can Israel stand its ground and
this potential new Middle East I do not
understand the American policy on one
hand they are trying to shape the Middle
East are trying to create this so-called
pragmatic Muslim states which Egypt
Saudi Arabia Jordan
and on the other hand they say couldn't
care less as they're leaving the region
and and the way we see it from Israel
the future of the region will be decided
not in Washington but somewhere between
Moscow and Ankara and the new
sykes-picot on the future of the next
hundred years of the Middle East is
discussed mainly in Russia so the idea
that you can influence without being
there probably this is American interest
probably they do not depend on energy
that comes from the Middle East their
economic and political interest is in
the Far East India China or South
America I do not blame the Americans but
III don't understand their aspiration to
shape the new Middle East by trying to
create this new this coalition and by
pulling out all the forces of something
Mediterranean and from Syria yeah there
has been turmoil in the United States
recently with some of the freshmen
Democrats facing backlash over
statements that weren't too friendly
towards Israel all this time Israel
enjoyed American support no matter which
of its parties was in power should
Israel now be afraid of the Democratic
Party becoming a lot less friendly
towards it I do believe that although
not many Israelis understand or agree to
my language but they agree to the same
assumptions that that yes
America is a great friend but America or
at least
most Americans do not support our second
wall which means all what we do on the
eastern side of the 67 lines so I don't
see that we should be afraid of a
Democratic president or Democratic
majority and Senate or Congress because
this is a way I understand the American
voices so tell me something do you think
the international pressure on Israel
ever gets strong enough that it will
actually influence its Palestinian
policies in other words does Israel even
care what the Americans are Europeans
think really I think that international
pressure can be positive only if it
comes with rational plants the idea of
two-state solution is accepted by
Israelis but but we have to be very very
confident that we shall get peace and we
shall not get more violence and mortar
if this will be the combination yes I
think that international intervention it
is not pressure will be very helpful yes
Admiral
thank you very much for this interview
while we're talking to Admiral on the
Isle on former head of Israel Shin Bet
Security Service and commander-in-chief
of the Israeli Navy discussing the
future of the israeli-palestinian
standoff that's it for this edition of
sophie-anne Co I'll see you next time
[Music]